hello
hello hello testing testing testing
can you guys hear me
hey guys
welcome you guys are
on time
oh cool cool cool very cool very cool
very cool
so um i just collected some memes
just to set the mood for this
presentation a little bit
while we wait for the rest of the people
um where are you guys uh coming from
while the lag is really slow
okay somebody finds it funny
burnaby l.a brazil
the states argentina
marica philippines
vancouver
cool cool cool
very cool um what's your
favorite food favorite building
favorite architect what's your favorite
architect
philadelphia guatemala from mexico
california puerto rico kenya cool
la your teacher introduced me introduced
me this week and i watched a bunch of
your videos cool
the case study project
yeah no problem from miami
frank lloyd of course
herzog and [ __ ] love herzog into [ __ ]
foster
[Music]
zaha hadid
puerto rico is that an architect
i thought uh capsule tower
calatrava yes i also love calatrava oh
from toronto there's some calatrava fans
here
looks like
oh hi
okay so
i think we can get started now
so i um i asked you guys a poll
and um you guys wanted to talk about
school versus work
i thought you guys were going to want to
talk about money but
this is good and
just a bit of housekeeping um
as i'm going through the presentation if
you can just
uh say like okay or
oh yeah or like lol that would
help me feel like i'm not talking to
myself here
um and if you guys can go to the video
and give me a thumbs up
that would be awesome okay
so we are talking about school
versus work um
so i'm just gonna do a brief talk
and um at the end of it we'll do a q a
and um
you guys can interrupt me if you have
any questions um i'll be checking
checking in the chat from time to time
so
i'll try to answer your questions as i
go
oh also there is like a
25 second delay i just found out so
i'm not going to be able to respond
immediately to your questions so
just please be patient
and i will try to talk fast
by the way do any of you guys watch the
videos
at a faster speed
i i i got a comment on one of my videos
from someone saying watch it at 1.5
speed
you're welcome i was like do i talk
really slow
anyways um so
a lot of you have said that you've been
inspired to be an architect
after watching some of the design-y
videos
but i think you have to enjoy the
day-to-day of being an architect
which actually contains a lot of the
non-designy stuff like
detailing coordination code
and so i think you have to enjoy all
those things to be
successful in architecture you can be a
design
architect that's definitely a role
within architecture
but you won't make a lot of money
because unless you're like a senior
architect
because everyone wants to do design
right
so you sort of need to enjoy the more
technical aspects and um
just a bit about myself
i always thought of myself as a designer
like the more creative
uh the left brain type someone who
like loves the conceptual stuff but um
last year i became a licensed architect
and i
left my job at the time and
um i sort of sat down and
i tried to make a table of like what i
like to do what i don't like to do
what i'm good at and what i'm not good
at
and um because i really wanted my next
job to be aligned with
what i wanted to do and uh one of the
things that i learned from the little
session
is that a lot of the things that i hated
before when i was starting
my journey of like the internship
became my favorite things once i started
to
get good at it and understand it
so an example is construction admin
i hated the paperwork um i thought it
was just
really boring but after i got good at it
i i really enjoyed i think before i
mostly didn't even know what i was
reading like 80 of the time
and so i had to ask questions i have to
like figure things out and it was just
hard
and so i think that's why i really
didn't like it and so
um yeah i think you
like what you enjoy now and what you
think you enjoy you actually
don't really know until you start
working in the field
so um today i just want to compare the
key differences between school and work
and of course like on this channel
that's what i'm
trying to do i'm trying to shed some
light on what architects actually do
on a day-to-day basis
so i'm gonna be talking about the
difference between school
and work through the difference in
projects
so we're going to be talking about the
scale
the complexity and i just read a comment
saying i get more mesmerizing per minute
thank you we will talk about the
constraints and we will talk about the
difference
in the type of projects between school
and work
and through that we're going to talk
about how that affects
our lives and our day-to-day as an
architect
so in school you typically do
like one or two or three projects per
semester
and typically one semester is four
months
and so in those four months you're doing
research
programming concept design development
presentations but at work
that time skill is pretty stretched out
and not only that you're learning about
what you're learning about in school
only makes up a really really really
small
part of the actual project so
um the blue is the design
can you guys see my mouse
anyways so the blue part is the design
portion
and so we do the research
the planning um the concept
the design development all of that
uh but on top of that we have like
client meetings permits
city consultation public consultation
um engineering coordination construction
documents and construction documents is
like a really big
part of the part of the project
um and
yeah that's really only the beginning
part
of an architectural project uh the
construction
and the construction of men that takes
up a
huge huge huge portion of a project's
timeline
so in school your day-to-day
um or your week to week is going to look
pretty different
um but and at work it could look
something like this or
you could be doing the same thing day in
and day out
so depending on
oh man this is okay
yeah this is supposed to be a gif
so depending on what kind of project and
what kind of firm
and like what kind of position you're in
um
the in a lot of cases the design can be
only a really small portion
of what you're doing um
oh man is that jeff not playing
that sad okay anyways it was really
funny
so anyway so if the monotony is
something that really scares you
or doing non-designy stuff scares you um
don't worry there are ways to spice up
your day today
so you can work on smaller projects um
like renovations or residential projects
and i'll talk about this a little bit
later so in smaller projects the time
span is a lot shorter so you will be
doing
um you will have a more you will have
more variety to your days
um and then the second thing is you can
get licensed fast
so if you can manage projects
and if you know the whole process it's
going to be
easier for you to kind of step in and
step out of different phases
of a project so um
like you saw in my other slide uh in
school you're only trained to do a very
small portion
um of a full project so
so you're only gonna be useful for like
schematics or design development part of
a
real project so that's why the starting
pay for
a starting architect is so low
um and when you get licensed
um that's when you can go to like client
meetings and
manage the design and manage teams and
you know coordinate with engineers and
it's just
it's just more fun that way um
i mean you can do all of these other
things without getting licensed but the
client will have more
um they'll just have more
assurance in you if you're a licensed
architect and you will also have a good
understanding of all of these processes
so that's another advantage to getting
licensed
oh there we go now you can see the video
sorry i'm just trying to look at the
comments and
answer any questions if i can
okay so you wanted to see the last chart
again which
chart this chart
[Music]
um
i um tom you had a question
so um do i feel like school prepared me
well
for work
um my my program was a bachelor of
architectural science so um we did have
a pretty good focus on like
learning all the programs and we did
cover the basis of like
building code and building details
but i think i just had a really hard
time like
and we also um learned about the
construction processes
but i just had a really hard time like
grasping all the concepts without
actually doing the project myself
so um and it was just one
course so it was really hard for me to
kind of gain the context of the entire
um within the entire project
so i think it did prepare me in terms of
um like with all the softwares that i
had to use
and i think that is actually one of the
big things that
firms look at i'm just making sure that
you can
they can give you a task and you can do
it but
in terms of like being an architect and
leading a project i don't think that
i was prepared for that at all
um can you talk about social life in
school do you become really
good friends with fellow architecture
students or do you get
to socialize with other students oh okay
that's a good question
i mostly had friends in the architecture
program like
it was really really really hard to make
friends with
um kids in other programs
just because like you're spending all
day and all night
in architecture and i just felt a little
bit
like i wasn't able to like relate with
students in other programs um
but looking back i kind of wish i had
made more friends in other programs
because i think they can give you
a different life perspective and
they can teach you things that are
really important in life
that's not just architecture um
like when i uh so when i finished my
masters
i so i did my masters in toronto and i
came back to vancouver to work and
this is where i i grew up and so i kind
of left behind
my uh my architecture circle
and it was really hard uh but
i made new friends and most of my
friends here
are in like i have a lot of architecture
friends here too
from work but a lot of my friends here
are
like in finance or in real estate
um in animation and so
um i feel like
i well first of all i understood a lot
of
financial principles by having those
friends and
i think that's one of the things that is
really really lacking in architecture
school and it's such a good fundamental
fundamental to have in your life and so
um i do kind of wish that i had made
some of those friends
a little bit earlier so that i can start
thinking about those other things
earlier in life
um okay
lisa you asked um
since projects are so prolonged and
affirmed
are there days or weeks where you don't
do much work
no there are no days
where you don't do much work i mean um
no that's not necessarily true
[Music]
um yeah like i think you have
the really fast days and you do have the
really slow days
and for me the slow days the time just
passes so slow
um because you're kind of like trying to
figure out what to do but those are also
the days
um like if you worked a lot the week
before
and um another week is really slow you
can like
um or all the firms that i've worked at
you could leave early
on those days so you can kind of like
balance your time
that way
um so yeah like we are going to have a q
a portion
so let me just get through all my slides
and we can
do a proper q a but these questions are
really interesting
um okay so where was i monotony
and school project okay
so the difference in scale of the
projects
they uh they also have an impact on
uh how many people are going to be
working on a project so
in school typically it's like you and
maybe your partner
working on a project
and you might end up like that
and at work you are going to be a part
of a team
this was my old office the red hair girl
is me
and yeah so at work you're going to be a
part of a team
you you're going to be a part of a team
within your office
and also within like the larger scope of
the project
um where you're gonna be working with a
lot of different engineers
um like different stakeholders
uh if you're working on institutional
buildings you're going to be working
with builders
maybe interior designers so
it is a lot more fun in my opinion and
i think if you like being a part of
something that's bigger than yourself
then i think you will
really like it and
if you like working with a variety of
different people
and if you like drama you will like that
too
um also um i think when you
when you're starting a job like
collaboration
and being able to work with in a team is
one of the most important qualities that
firms look for
so i think it's a skill that's important
to
start like building up now if you're a
student
um just being able to work with other
people
and you know just like being a good
teammate
and then the next big difference is
uh complexity of the project
just gonna get some water
um okay so
in school mostly you're figuring out
the concept and the design
and you might figure out like the
fundamentals of
the structural system or the mechanical
system
um but you don't really need to figure
out how to build it
and the cost is not really a concern
um and at work that
is not true buildings are really really
complex and
these are construction drawings so
they're like blueprints
um do you guys know what they are
construction construction drawings
um yeah so a big chunk of your time is
gonna be spent creating construction
drawings
uh they're basically like a set of
really
clear and detailed instructions for the
contractors
okay and of course
because buildings are so complex we work
with
a lot of engineers
and so i included this slide because i
wanted to ask you guys if you think this
is true or not
okay so i'm gonna explain to you why
this overly simplified meme is
absolutely not true and i'm gonna
explain it
in legal terms and um in terms of
what we do so
engineers they have their own
specialization
like mechanical civil structural
electrical and they're liable
for those uh those uh that the work that
they do
and legally they have to stamp their
drawings
and say this is built to this standard
and
i give my professional assurance
and architects they have also their own
specializations which is
fire safety and accessibility
that's like making sure that anyone like
older people
or like people in wheelchairs they can
use the building
um just as well as any other person
and these standards vary from city to
city
vancouver is very very strict with
accessibility
so there's a lot more restrictions that
you have to get through
and all of this is through the building
code of course
and in terms of what we do um
while we are just like the engineers
and that we have our own specialization
um one of our main roles is
working with these different engineers
and
um the builder and kind of coordinating
everyone and this is actually a legal
responsibility it's called the
crp
and so what does that mean this means
that
engineers they don't really have to know
anything about
what architects do or what the other
engineers do
but architects have to know a little bit
about
what each of the engineers do and
what everyone else does so
um but you don't need to know
it in too much detail uh you just need
to know
um like the basics of how these
systems are gonna have an impact on the
function of the buildings
um and typically you would uh
like outline the spatial and functional
criteria for the engineers and they'll
put together a design for you
and um so i typically like work
backwards so you kind of start from how
the person would use the space
um so if it's like an office they would
want
bright light and maybe the client wants
warm light so you just try to think
about like the aesthetics
the location of these fixtures and the
function of them
and uh also think about what the
engineer
might not be thinking about so like a
mechanical engineer
he's gonna let's say he wants to put in
um a ventilation system in an office
he's not necessarily gonna be thinking
about how loud it's gonna be he
he just cares about the ventilation
right um
so a part of your job is to try to think
about all those other things
um so yeah that's a big part of your
role
coordinating the engineers and checking
their drawings and
making sure they work with the overall
[Music]
concept
and another very big difference
from school is that you need to work
with these scary people
called contractors
and uh yeah they typically come on board
when the space is
um all the drawing all the construction
drawings are done and
the space is ready to be built and this
is the fun part of the project
and um having a good relationship with
your contractors and
earning their respect is really really
important
um like you have to set standards and
set expectations and establish roles at
the
beginning of the project and that will
save you a lot of headache
down the line because you're going to be
working with these people all day
in and out on some really complex
problems
and a lot of contractors they have a
pre-conceived notion of architects
as people who don't really know how to
build
so it's really important that you learn
your construction
learn your details and know what you're
drawing and
how it's built
especially if you're a female architect
actually
there's just going to be a lot of
prejudice
stacked up against you so you know if
there's like one place
to put your foot down and be assertive
it would be on the construction site
and you really wanna know your stuff and
if somebody challenges you you want to
be firm and
stand your ground and
yeah i think having a good construction
process is kind of art of its own and
um every office will have their own
standards
and um i'll i might do a video on this
and cover this on mundane mondays
um anyways yeah what i'm trying to say
here is that
like buildings and construction projects
are really really complex
so you kind of need to know a little bit
about everything and be really good
with working with other people
i'm gonna try to answer some questions
vincent cruz um would you say that the
architect
is the conductor of a project or
is that someone else's responsibility um
yes i would definitely say that
architects are
sort of a conductor of a project and i
think more and more
as buildings get more and more complex
um we will see this uh
role happening this role becoming more
important
like if you compare buildings now to
just like 30 or 40 years ago
we have so many new systems like
building envelope systems
um like waterproofing systems to make
the buildings more energy efficient
that every specialization becomes
um like really complex so you really
need someone who's
gonna be a good coordinator and um
not only coordinate those systems but be
able to
work with the city and the client to
like manage expectations
and um yeah like i think
that role is so important and um
it's really the difference between like
if a project's gonna be good
and kind of well every project is going
to be pretty stressful but
um you're the one who's going to be
making it less stressful
okay
[Music]
um
okay gonna move on
so
yeah the other
difference would be the other big
difference would be the
constraints
so in school you have um
the program uh site
client uh budget well i don't know if
you guys have a budget or not do you
guys have a budget in your project
um i i didn't when i was in school
so yeah you would get like a
hypothetical program
hypothetical site hypothetical client
and i guess yeah typically no budget
and uh in real life
uh most projects have a specific budget
and the time you need to work with
you have your fees um which is like the
time that you're allotted to work on a
particular project
and you have the construction budget um
so
this is how a lot of design decisions
are made
and this is how like decisions
like materials cladding
um the systems that you're going to be
using
how you're going to decide all of that
and uh yeah you kind of have to keep
cost estimating as you go
and try to adjust your design to the
budget
um i don't know if you guys know what
value engineering
is um but
do you guys know so it's it's
like when you revise the design to uh
make it more
cost effective and like we've had a
value engineering exercise in pretty
much every project that i've worked on
so
it's very common apparently you can
design
down but you can never design up
somebody told me
so you should always design to uh
high quality and once the value
engineering comes in you can
design down
um yeah and also you're going to have a
lot of clients who's going to want to
cut your ideas
mostly on budget concerns
um and yeah so most of these aspects
like program
sites budget they're all given to you
yeah the program sometimes in school you
get to choose a program
but typically at work you don't get to
and
you can kind of go as far as choosing
the firm that you want to work for so if
you want to work on
more residential buildings you can go to
a residential firm
but yeah you typically don't get to
choose a program unless
you're involved in the pre-design phase
uh which is which would be cool
but anyways like within that program
there is quite a bit of flexibility
um and that's also kind of the fun part
okay so yeah like one of the
top requirements that you have to
consider at work is the zoning
requirements
um do you guys know what zoning is
[Music]
um peter you asked how you would
calculate the cost while designing
so we actually work with a
cost estimator so there's a thing called
like um cost estimation a cost
estimation b
cost estimation c cost estimation d
and like the d would be the most rough
one
so you just calculate that based on like
the rough square footage of your
building and you multiply that
by if it's like the office then there's
a
number for an office and if it's like a
residential then
residential with like wood frame
construction then there's a number for
that
so that's like the most rough that's
cost estimate estimate d
and then cost estimate c it gets a
little bit more specific
into like what materials you're going to
use
what kind of structure you're going to
use and then
cost estimate b gets even more detailed
into like the type of finishes that
you're going to use and it's just
getting
it just keeps getting more and more
specific so you work with the cost
estimator
and you would kind of show that to the
client and if the client's like whoa
that's
way too expensive then you kind of like
work with them to
reduce the design um
and another thing that we typically do
is
we like let's say we're
designing a cladding right and we
wanna we have like four different
cladding options we have
like something wood something
that's like metals maybe zinc cladding
um maybe concrete panels and
so this is a really
strange part of the construction process
and i
i'm curious if other countries
have it like that too but at least here
in vancouver like we have to
call the manufacturer and ask them like
okay how much is this gonna cost
and they'll give you details about their
products
and they'll give you like a rough
estimate and there doesn't seem to be
a um
i don't know like a universal database
for these materials
so i always found that kind of
inefficient
um anyways
so yeah i hope that answered your
question
peter
uh value engineering is removing trees
right
no it's not
um yeah value engineering
uh equals yeah client doesn't want to
spend that's
true
um okay so
do you think it's harder to be accepted
into university okay so i'll
answer more of these questions later um
if you guys can yeah like keep
populating the chat with questions
but also if you can try to remember them
for later so that i can
um answer them in the q a that would be
awesome
okay so we talked did we talk about
zoning
i don't know okay anyway so
we have zoning requirements as well that
we have to really consider
so
um most cities are
divided into little zones so you'll have
like
an industrial zone a residential zone
um like a commercial zone
and within that zone um
you can have a variety of different
buildings but
mostly you can only have the type that
it's
zoned for so um
within those requirements the city will
say
um oh but you can you can have like 80
commercial retail
so that's your job as the architect to
figure out
what you're allowed to put in there um
read the zoning requirements
because um obviously you want the space
to be as democratic and
like good for the public as possible but
still
meet the requirements from the clients
um and we also have the building code
requirements
so what i said before is architects are
responsible for the fire safety and
accessibility
so this is going to restrict
what you can build and how you build it
so let's just say
for example um the zoning
allows for 5000 square feet
of um
[Music]
like commercial space in the building
and the client wants a big mezzanine
so we decide to split up that 5 000
square feet
oh you guys probably don't know feet
you guys probably work in meters okay
um square feet is a
canadian and it's like a north american
form of measurement but
anyways so let's say you take that 5 000
square feet
into like a third um
like a third of that five thousand
square feet would be
um like sixteen hundred so let's say
uh you and the client decided okay we
want that to be the mezzanine
and the client wants to put in like 20
people on the mezzanine
so you know after doing some design work
you guys figured okay like 16 000 square
feet is probably
whatever a good amount of floor space
but the building code it only
allows for a maximum of a thousand
square feet
of mezzanine in that area because
you need to have a maximum distance from
any uh
place in the space to the exit
so that in case there is a fire people
can quickly go outside and
be safe so
that would be a constraint and it'll get
even trickier if the zoning says
okay like within that 5 000 feet
uh square feet you can only have you can
only have
one third of that space's office and um
the two-thirds has to be commercial
um then you just have to like work with
the client
to try to figure out like okay what
use do we want do we really want to have
in the mezzanine like can we bring
some of those 20 people downstairs
like what do you want to do with the
ground floor how much it's gonna
cost to construct the mezzanine um is it
even worth it now
and so yeah there's a lot of back and
forth with the city
and uh and the client and so you
have to try to manage those expectations
um and yeah so these the zoning and the
building code it's kind of the basis
for for all design projects um
unless you're kind of designing in the
middle of nowhere
okay and then uh we also have
to consider the public interest so
let's say you're designing this building
in a mostly residential area
and you might get all these nimbies
uh if you don't know what nimbies are uh
it
stands for not in my backyard so it's
these people who have houses in the area
who are like no i don't want this thing
here
anyways so here in vancouver there is a
very
extensive like public consultation
process which sometimes can get a little
anyways um and yeah like one time we
had this project in this chinatown
neighborhood
and uh the building had white brick
on the cladding and uh the residents
were like nah
we we're not having that here white
means bad luck
and so uh we had to change the color of
the cladding
and so yeah there is also that
part of like trying to manage the
public's interests
as well
so in the end uh
i think that's kind of the difference
between
a good architect and a bad architect
i hope you guys get this reference
because otherwise
i will look like a fool
this is walter white from breaking bad
he went from good to bad
okay anyways um so
yeah the architect is trying to straddle
all these different requirements
of the code and zoning and site
and the budget and you're trying to
create
good architecture and um like you're
trying to create something that's good
for the public
um while also satisfying the client's
wishes
so like a bad architect will say
like oh it is what it is like that's
what the code says that's what the
zoning says
because like the client doesn't know the
engineers don't know the interior
designers don't know
because they don't understand code
and they don't understand zoning so um
they usually just take the architect's
word for it
and if the architect doesn't care and
doesn't want to spend
time like trying to figure out a better
way to
provide the client with what they want
um
you know he can just say it is what it
is
and the client will pretty much go with
like
what the architect says and um
i think a good architect will try to
like work and rework
and just try to navigate around all
these constraints
to try to create a good scenario
for everyone um
yeah i i think if you're yeah
if you're a bad architect you're really
like doing a disservice to your client
and yeah i i
also worked with um
a architect who was much much much older
and much much much more experienced than
me
and um like
although it never said anything in the
code or in the zoning he just had so
much experience
that he kept saying like oh the city
will never let us do this
i've tried this before the city will
never let us do this
and so everyone kind of takes his word
for it because he
has dealt with the city so many times
and
you will kind of encounter this a lot
there's a lot of
like unwritten rules that you just have
to know by experience
and that's why even if you're licensed
like myself i got licensed really early
like you still need
to work for so many years to be a good
architect right
um yeah
you just finished season four
how lucky i wish there were more seasons
of
breaking bad
[Music]
uh is it true that you cannot do
anything else if you're in architecture
school
oh um
i think from
for most people they
really get absorbed by architecture
school
but when i look back on it like those
were really
i look back on those times very fondly
because
once you leave architecture school
you don't have that many opportunities
to just focus
on um a project that you're
interested in so yeah
and i mean it's not necessarily true
like you can definitely
manage your time to do other things
like i i had a friend
who was like going to the gym all the
time
and like making food and
um taking dance classes
uh so yeah it's just based on how you
manage your time i think
okay and then the last big difference
is the type of buildings you can work on
so uh in school you will be working on
all different types of buildings um like
residential
institutional uh museums libraries
uh maybe prisons i don't know um
and at work you
um each project or sorry each firm
will be specializing
in a particular building type
mostly um if you're like a small to
mid-size
firm and if you're a large firm like ibi
or like stantec then you might be doing
like all different types of buildings
but there is a pretty big distinction
between
like a couple of the main categories
so like a residential project is
really really different from an
institutional project
and that's really different from a
commercial
or retail project and that's also really
different from an office project
so uh you don't really need to decide
exactly uh like what type of buildings
you want to work on but
it's good to try to develop some sort of
a specialty
in my opinion because i think it'll make
you more valuable
and
i think it'll also determine like your
career path
and your day-to-day
and the type of clients you work with
because yeah like if you're working on a
institutional building
then you're gonna have multiple clients
you're gonna have a lot of different
stakeholders
and if you're working on residential
then you're going to
probably just have the the owners of the
house right
so a lot of people say that residential
architecture is kind of like marriage
counseling
but i think that's also um that can also
be very rewarding because you're
providing a home for these people right
um yeah so
uh typically like the smaller the
project the more you can
do it by yourself i did mention this in
one of my other videos
um and this also means that you can
finish
the projects faster so uh
and it probably means that you can be
more involved in
different phases of a project and in
a bigger project you can kind of only do
it in a firm like you can't really do it
as a
sole proprietor uh or it would be really
hard to without some help
um anyway so it just means that
you're gonna be more of a coordinator or
like a project manager
and it also means like you're going to
be
just overseeing a lot of moving pieces
um what else yeah i think your
your interest in a particular typology
is definitely important i think
um you should try to think about that if
you're in school now
but i think what you're interested in
now if you're in school
is also going to be really different
from like once you try working on a
different typology
um because it's you're going to see how
it affects your day-to-day and
like your interactions with the client
and yeah i think after trying out a
couple of different typologies you can
you can make a make a decision
so that is the end of the presentation
i hope i didn't crush anybody's dreams
uh i'm just trying to give you a a
realistic understanding
of what it's like to work in the field
so
okay so i'm gonna move on to the
questions now
uh lauren
what do you think will happen
to architecture in the future do you
think architects will be useful in the
future
that is a really good question oh hi stu
stu is my friend from architecture
school
um okay so that's a
good question it's also a hard question
uh so in the future i think
uh technology is gonna advance and
i think i mean technology is going to
advance
in a way that like how
revit changed the industry right like
you're not just doing 2de drawings
you're building the 3d model and at the
same time that's
uh building your construction drawings
and
everything is integrated together so i
think in the future
um these building technologies and
design technologies are going to be
far more advanced and so i think the
value of the architect
is not going to be so much on like being
able to draw
or like put together details
i think the value of the architect is
really gonna be more
um like their soft skills uh like we
talked about
before like navigating the zoning and
code and
navigating through everyone's
expectations
and you know that those soft skills are
hard like
that requires empathy that requires like
listening skills
um it requires uh having sensitivity to
the context
and uh strategic thinking
um so like
like look at the pandemic like we've
lost a lot of jobs
and a lot of jobs have become
automated and we're seeing that the jobs
that are not automated
or sorry the jobs that will stay are the
ones that
require um like a human touch right
so yeah that's what i think is gonna
happen in the future
um and i think buildings
are also gonna advance in the future
although
like the architecture industry does seem
to move a lot slower compared to others
um i think buildings are gonna be come
much more complex
so in the near future um i think we're
gonna see
more um like more specializations
popping up and i think people who can
manage those little areas are gonna
become successful and i also made a
little video
um on my channel uh called deep work
that book really um
changed my thinking on like how i should
be developing my skills um
and yeah like the book is saying that
it's
people who can learn new technologies
really fast and adapt to it really fast
are gonna be um better off in the future
so yeah you guys should actually start
thinking about this now
like the industry if you're in school
like the industry is not gonna be
the same um when you start working uh
then when it is now right so um don't
just like take my word for it i think
you should
think about how the industry is going to
change in the future
um and yeah next question
malory okay
uh to be honest how do you like working
with interior designers
um i actually love
working with interior designers um
and i i really
enjoy uh working with them because
i felt like there was a lot that i could
learn from them
like they are not really dealing with
all the constraints like the building
code and
uh the zoning right so they really have
to sell to the clients
like a feeling which is i think a lot
harder to sell
than um something that's based on
such pragmatic constraints so they have
like amazing
client management skills and um are
really
uh really good skills and like selling
their ideas
which i think a lot of architects could
improve on
um so yeah i really enjoyed working with
them
um like sometimes it is it does get a
little bit frustrating
when they don't like understand all the
code
aspects of a project but i mean those
are minor
details and those are things that you
can help them with
uh is handwriting going to be obsolete
i no no i
i think most of our work we do with
computers
but there is something really nice
about seeing a really nicely handwritten
note
i'm not gonna lie
[Music]
what softwares are most important to
learn as architecture students or
young architects um i think
personally revit but
uh since i got my new macbook
i haven't been able to install revit on
here
so i have been um trying
out like archicad and vectorworks
and it does seem like i don't know like
half of the firms here in vancouver use
vectorworks
and the other half use revit i think
revit is
definitely more popular but like
there's a lot more little finicky
details and
uh learning revit is a big learning
curve
um however i think
revit can still give you the best like
competitive advantage
when you're applying to firms
um and apparently if you know dynamo
that's uh dynamo is kind of like
grasshopper for revit
so apparently that's really useful as
well
that's something that someone who works
at stantec told me
um
do you feel like the specialization of
architecture has diminished the role of
architect to just specialists that's
a really interesting question um
i think there are actually two paths
that you can go
in architecture and yeah one of them
is being a specialist at a larger firm
because they can
typically afford to pay for someone to
just do ca or just do detailing
and i think there is a lot of value in
that too and i think there are people
who can
uh who really thrive off of that and
enjoy that
um and then i think the other
way to go is being a generalist is
which is something that i'm really
trying to do i am trying to become
um more generalist like i i have my
t right like i want to build up
knowledge and all the other things but i
do want to
have some specialties like i want to be
i want to get really good at
um passive house i want to get really
good at
like um communication and
communicating to clients
but i think like personally i
enjoy doing a bunch of different things
like i
don't think i could be in a very
monotonous
environment for a very long time so
um yeah that's just my take on it
oh my god i realized
i realized that my egg salad was on the
screen
sorry guys yeah i did make egg salad
today it was really
it was okay it wasn't that good
my mom's recipe for egg salad was much
better because she added
cucumber and this one only had onions in
it so
it wasn't it was okay
um
okay what at work
that's interesting
okay so what at work still
inspires you to
be an architect um
i think for me oh sorry
was it what at work still inspires you
to be
a great architect
um i think for me
it's actually just that
like i like growing i like learning
um i think there is an intrinsic
happiness you can gain from like
becoming better at something and
like pushing yourself to be the best you
can be
and i'm like i said i'm trying to become
more of a generalist so i'm building up
my soft skills and
um all my technical skills at the same
time
um well while also focusing on areas
like uh
yeah like communication and passive
house
um and then i'm also inspired by
like educating younger people um so
i think architecture is a really
humbling experience in that you
understand that it's not really a
one-man show
when i was in school i used to have a
big ego
like i used to think that oh i'm this
super creative genius that can design
these like
really cool things but
uh now i know that no matter how good of
an architect i am
i'm only going to be making a tiny
little difference in the world
um but like teaching and like
trying to inspire the next generation i
feel like
i can make a bigger impact um
like within the industry and also in the
world
um and also i
i want to try making good
um like socially and environmentally
sustainable architecture
that's also culturally significant
and also um just like working with
different people
and like building meaningful
relationships and helping people create
something that
they feel like they were a part of um
and yeah just like being a part of
something that's bigger than myself
so yeah i think those are some of the
things that
inspire me okay
so next question
how to choose architecture firm to
apply for first internship
that is a great question um
so i think
uh there's maybe there's like three
parts to this
question like
yeah like there's the application how do
i
get a job and then there's like maybe i
should also talk about
um how can you be a good architect
once you uh once you or sorry how can
you
become like a valuable member of the
firm once you start working
um so
yeah you can basically prepare yourself
you you should if you haven't already
and you're in school like you should
basically just start putting together a
portfolio now
um like look at other portfolio
examples online and like get a sense of
which ones are good and which ones are
bad
and um like
just try to have good projects like good
clear graphics
because um
yeah like when you start working that's
gonna be your department like graphics
and that's uh well that is what you're
really good at right out of school right
so graphics imagery renderings
diagramming
and make sure your portfolio is clear
and
concise um and
softwares uh that's
yeah like try to get your hands on or
try to practice as many softwares as
possible
um i heard somebody
say like revit is not a good program to
learn
but maybe you can elaborate on that
um okay and then uh yeah just like
teamwork i think if you have like one or
two
uh team projects that kind of
shows that you can work in a team and
work with other people
and if you can have a project that's
like multi-disciplinary like i did a
project with
building science students and that was a
part of my portfolio and
um that was something that they really
liked seeing
uh so yeah something like that is good
if you have any like extracurriculars
that's really good too
if you were a part of the student
council that looks pretty good and
that's something that has come up quite
a few times like during
um during my interviews and also like
network
um try to get awards uh try to get
referrals from your profs
that's that's that's important
um and yeah like if you can get a summer
internship that's good
and um yeah that'll look
good on your resume and it'll also like
increase your starting
salary if you can get internships
between
between the summers and school
um yeah
and
i guess yeah i guess when you first
start
applying like i guess once you finish
school you're gonna be
applying for like all kinds of jobs but
i would also
um urge you to
think about like seriously think about
where you want to work
because a bigger firm is not necessarily
better
if it's your first job um and a higher
salary isn't necessarily better either
so um i think you should be thinking
about things like are you going to be
working closely with the principals um
are you gonna be um
like are is the firm gonna help you get
licensed fast
so um that's really important because
once you get licensed you can get a
salary bump um like i had a
uh 20 000 salary bump after i got
licensed
and that was at a different firm so
that's
really important to consider so you
might be taking
a lower pay at your first job but if
they're going to help you
in your career i think that's more
important than
than yeah going to a bigger firm for a
bigger pay
okay
um
um currently uh so there was a question
[Music]
what building types are you working on
currently so
i have mostly worked on
um ti's like um
commercial retail um tenant improvements
so like retrofits and renovation um
i've done offices uh residential
buildings
but i haven't really worked on a lot of
institutional buildings
so um i'm actually between jobs right
now
i'm starting my new job next week
and uh there will be a much bigger focus
on
institutional project so i'm excited
about that
[Music]
how hard is is it to find an internship
do you think it's possible to find one
in third year or would it be better to
put efforts to
finding year four internships
um i don't really know
what the market is like right now um
with the pandemic but i would just try
to
find an internship um
and when you sing internship you mean
like working between
uh the summers between like third and
fourth year right
so yeah i would just try to find and
find work
um whenever you can like but if you
don't it's not a huge problem like i
never worked between the summers
i was like at the beginning at the beach
or like traveling
but um i was still able to get a job
after i finished uh but there is a
uh salary difference like if you worked
between the summers like you will
have a higher starting pay when you
start like officially working
hmm do i have a
personal favorite piece of architecture
um i really like um
carlos garpa's work like he's a really
master manipulator of space
i love stephen hall's work i don't know
if you guys know stephen hall
he's amazing at like playing with light
i also like
carlos scarpa's work i don't know if you
guys know him he actually never built
like
a full building but he's done a bunch of
renovations
in uh venice and
he embeds a lot of like symbolism and
meaning into his work
and they're all because they're all in
very small tiny little spaces in venice
they're all like really detailed and
just really beautiful spaces to go
through
um i also like
um well like if we're just talking
architects i also really like bjr
kangols
like i just really like how he combines
like different typologies and he's like
a master
master communicator so i think he's
really cool
[Music]
uh what do you think your strengths are
what do you think your best strengths
are as an architect
or what part of the process do you enjoy
the most
from robert um i think
well i kind of mentioned this at the
beginning of the
presentation like i always thought i was
my best strength was
designing like i love designing and i've
always
just identified myself as a designer
but i think after working
i realized i really love the
construction process
and i actually love like the
construction
administration side of the project
because that's where
like a lot of things are happening at
the same time right
and that's when you're actually like
building the building
you're getting to see the thing that you
drew
get built and um
there's a lot more interactions and
there's a lot of like
problem solving like if there is
something that
is that the contractor doesn't know how
to build properly on site then
he'll send you questions and you kind of
like try to figure it out and you send
back answers and it's like a back and
forth and
i just really like that process
so yeah i think that's i think that's my
favorite
and also i love um
like researching and um
like creating pro programmatic diagrams
and also i love like presenting work and
trying to create
presentations that um are really easy
and understandable to um like
non-architect
so um i think that's something that i'm
gonna
try to work on and it's something that
um like my new firm and i are gonna
actively
try to work on because we are doing a
lot of projects right now
in the pre-design to like schematic
to feasibility phase so like the early
stages
so there's a lot more like diagramming
and like communication that needs to
happen
so yeah that's the part that i'm trying
to
focus a little bit more on right now
um how in school and university
would you know if you're going to like
architecture if you haven't studied
architecture before
and whether it'll be a good fit it's
from andrea
so
that's a lot of talking
um so for me
so i'm assuming you are in high school
or
uh you're in another program thinking of
going into architecture
so this is just my experience
and i didn't know anything about
architecture before i went to
architecture school
um and i didn't even know
that i was gonna like architecture
i was in grade 12 i was supposed to
choose a major
and i used to paint
a lot like i used to stay after school
and
paint these like delicate oil paintings
and like one of the student teachers not
even a teacher she
like recommended she was like oh why
don't you try out for architecture
school like why don't you
try putting together a portfolio and so
i did that and um
i got into a program in toronto and
i wanted to try living in toronto so i
went there
and i ended up really liking
architecture
and so i think it's a i think you won't
really know until you try it
really um you can ask
a hundred different questions and people
are gonna give you all different types
of answers but
i think in the end it's something that
you kind of have to try
and um even once you
are already in architecture there's a
lot of people who
like fall out of love with it and
there's a lot of people who weren't that
into it before
who like really fall into love with it
after they start working because they
realize oh like i actually
like doing this part of architecture so
it's kind of a
constant discovery process
okay
okay
hmm
you guys have a lot of questions
and i'm just trying to answer them
like from the top i guess i'm kind of
starting
in the middle um
how how can you improve your design
skills uh my teacher always tells me
that my designs are really bad
or really basic okay oh
um
i think you just improve by practicing
and doing a lot of different
iterations um i think
iteration is key like
typically i and this might actually
cover some of the other questions like
some of the other design questions
so um my design process
um for school
was i would just do
a lot of research about all the
different constraints like i would
research um
the site i would research uh
everything about the views the program
the context
and just like fill my head
with research do a [ __ ] load of research
and um i just like sketch it out sketch
out a lot of
like programming diagrams in my
sketchbook
and um for some projects the
concept comes out kind of naturally and
it's
i think once you kind of get a handle on
the concept then
you can improve your design because
if you have a good concept then you're
like every aspect of your design is
gonna be
fed by your concept right so
if you have um
a concept that aligns with the structure
um the program and like the function and
the form of the building then that's
like
what's considered a good design and so
um
yeah like you want to try to like get
the concept out as early as possible
and like i don't know some people
like create a concept and then they just
like build off of that
but i think for me it's the best when
you just like
let the concept come out of the research
and um let the concept come out of the
initial sketches that you're doing um
and then um i usually try to
uh let the function kind of drive the
form
so i do a lot of like uh diagrams a lot
of like
formal diagrams and i just try to
think about the functions of the space
and i just do
like a hundred different iterations of
um how that would look in massing
um so uh just like
do a hundred different iterations of
like the same thing on rhino or sketchup
or whatever
3d program you're using um
and oh i actually got a really good book
recently
never mind i can't find it um
but yeah it's i'll put the link to the
book
in the details of the video but yeah it
just gives you
different strategies to do
do messing
so
here it is
it is called conditional design an
introduction to elemental architecture
and so it has all of these strategies
on how you can iterate through
different massing options so like
if you want to merge these two forms
it shows you how to how to merge it on
this plane
and it also shows you how to merge it
vertically
and it also like shows you
how to integrate circulation so
um let's say this is overlap
it's trying to show you how you can um
create like an overlapping condition
between
amongst like two different uh masses
and so it shows you that you can do it
like this and like this
and um if you're overlapping it
on top of this geometry you can insert
the circulation um in this way or this
way you don't know it just gives you a
lot of
options and yeah it's a good book
okay
um did i answer your question he said
how do you do designs um yeah so i just
do a lot of iterations
um and
yeah sometimes the concept comes out
later and sometimes like
as you're in the more developed phases
of the project you have to
change the design because you realize
like the concept that you have
you you found out later is way better
so yeah that's why architects work
long days and long nights
okay so i think
so that was an hour and 40 minutes
so i think i'm gonna start wrapping it
up i know that i didn't answer
like so many questions but um
maybe i'll do another live session
oh there's my excellent again uh maybe
i'll do another live session where i
just answer the questions um i think
that will be
a good one so um
yeah that's pretty much it
um if you guys have any other questions
like just throw it in the comments i
think the chat will be off
after this and
[Music]
um yeah like thank you so much guys for
joining this was really really cool
like really fun and um hopefully
i'll do this again soon
and is there anything else dad
i hope you guys found this helpful
and um i'm gonna go through all the
comments
and uh the questions later
um so yeah um have a great
rest of your friday or saturday
and i'm gonna go and grab some dinner
okay cool bye